savait qu'il était kim kardashian moi du
tout pas du tout quoi je connaissais pas
du tout ah ouais donc je ne sait rien
d'elle je savais la famille kardashian
c'est les séries que j'ai jamais regardé
d'accord donc vous saviez pas du tout
que c'était pourquoi est ce que vous
l'avez choisi l appareil se sont dit
avant qu'on a choisi c'est son diamant
soit vous avez vous avez eu une info pas
il était sur internet tant que c'est pas
moi qui le dis mais comment on est venu
vous voir pour vous parler de cette
affaire on recevait des connaissances et
des connaissances qui vous ont dit quoi
qu'en dise et intéresser une opération
travaux diamant dans un cas rare qu'on
sait tout de suite que ça vaut 400 est à
dépendre la couleur 4 5 6 millions
d'euros donc là on s'y intéresse parce
que des acteurs vous prenez 4 millions
n'a pas alors comment vous avez su
qu'elle serait seul ce soir là vous avez
affaire à lenquête c'est compliqué oui
mais ces appartements comme on l'a su
javier et hop vous avez opération enfin
dans une mine de renseignements ont
heureusement où ça à l'hôtel non
l'automne pas tellement ont certainement
de son entourage mais c'est pas moi qui
ai géré ce avant que je pourrais le jeu
d'accord on va voir vos québécois dans
les détails a eu des fuites quadri livre
alors alors si si et si vous saviez ce
que vous cherchiez vous avez ma jun très
grande valeur comme il l'a dit ces
bijoux 7 / tu ne sais pas compliqué de
savoir qu'elle les avait puisque vous le
savez et les exposer tout le temps donc
si vous la connaissiez pas vos amis
voilà le saviez donc à la base vous y
allez vraiment pour ses bijoux là pour
cette bague surtout à mons pour la bague
exactement alors le soir vous décidé
d'agir elle est donc seul dans cet hôtel
parisien de luxe
il y à un veilleur de nuit mais son
garde du corps est avec sa soeur en
boîte de nuit
oui bah c'est normal le gars du gol l'a
raccompagnée chez elle et la paix vous
adresser il s'en va s'est enfermée chez
elle
surtout à l'hôtel ils disent et secure
bah oui normalement les panneaux dont il
dresse ses services il intéressé ça n'a
pas été normale
alors vous le saviez tout ça on pas
qu'elle avait une si faible aux
protections vous savez qu'il n'était
plus là on attendait ce moment
bien sûr on sait qu'on a été on l'a fait
à deux heures du matin donc le
cambriolage vous avez donc dans cet
hôtel à bille en faux policiers alors
non on rentre pas en fonte
positionneront rentant betis d'accord
tranquillement donc le soir comme ça
vous fait du vtt croquer vous avez gilet
réfléchissant moi j'avais un an je les
avais
ces 100 jours donc l'hôtel étaient
fermés ou bien où s'élaborent sur la
route est ouverte pour ça on s'en était
assurée aussi elle était ouverte
d'accord vous rentrez et vous faites
quoi non sous le porche
il ya deux caméras en eau ouais on avait
apporté de quoi les camoufler mais on
s'est aperçu que c'était trop ton
pouvait pas le faire d'accord mais en y
réfléchissant bien on s'est aperçu
qu'elle servait à rien pourquoi passer
des personnalités qui viennent doivent
pas se faire photographier le veulent
pas se rebeller défendre les grands
hôtels comme ça les caméras ne marche
pas pas dans ces endroits là div c pas
un grand total ans et encore ils ont
très très modeste
c est lors bernard montiel sa dont le
nom c'est une résidence privée en fait
alors c'est pas vraiment un hôtel c'est
un endroit très spécifique dans paris où
effectivement les plus grandes stars
loue cet endroit il ya un gardien à
l'entrée il ya un service un room
service si on veut etc
mais ce n'est pas un hôtel comme on peut
l'imaginer et donc est donc là il n'y a
pas de caméra en fait non parce que
basque il ya beaucoup de relations
coupables dirais je il ya de nombreux
hommes d'affaires qui viennent passer
l'après-midi et partir après vous le
saviez ça vous saviez que caméra web et
s'il savait tout non mais vous le saviez
évidemment que vous saviez bah oui vous
le saviez vous on le sait c'est interdit
moi je ne savais pas et si c'est
interdit pouvais me ramener qui vous
voulez mais personne ne soit parce que
c'est pas filmés alors donc là vous
arrivez en vététistes claqué ce
gouverneur alors on s'habille en étroit
d'abord d'accord on s'habille avec des
cacahuètes policiers casquette de
policier mais c'est des produits de
cinéma qu'on achète facilement acheter
ça ou vous avez trouvé ça sur internet
sur les réseaux sociaux sont d'accord
donc vous voilà c'est d'accord on a mis
ça on a mis un an nous moi je suis
quelqu'un de mon collègue des cagoules
et le troisième est resté
j'ai découvert il a frappé à la porte et
la conscience police police ouvrez
ouvrez tu as dit oui j'aime bien je
pense est d'accord au concierge il a
ouvert la porte a dit vous venez pour
l'adresse vous voulez qu'on a droit oui
c'est un endroit connu pour ça aussi
oui quand les dealers de paris savent ce
qui se passe en vendant droite ou par
lots cette ut prison hausse avait coûté
3 ans le sam est donc donc le second
siège si vous venez pour la drogue et là
vous lui dites quoi donc bah ils se
plient latorre de la police à bron plus
tard on saura qu'il était sans papiers
c'est un autre sujet oui monsieur mais
c'est un autre sujet et donc moi et que
donc ici c'est plié aurait il s'est
laissé faire il a pas discuté pendant
qu'au rond qui discutaient nous on l'a
entouré bon j'ai attrapé le bras je les
couche et j'ai fait un petit balayette
j'ai envoyé par terre bon là je me suis
retourné sur lui j'ai attaché à voter
oui c'est bon c'est lui qui l'a plaqué
au sol et qui lui a mis je crois le bras
on rigolait oui mais je rigole pas du
tout simplement c'est ça qui la
trahissent et l'adn qui avait sur ses
bras ses moyens non en fait c'est pas le
mieux votre adn qui avait été dans un
hold up en belgique et leur médaille
vous à retrouver comme ça
aulas est ce que vous dites dans le
livre en tout cas alors alors le mb oui
alors y'en a qui est pas d'accord
le concierge aussi séquestré donc que
l'émission a retrouvé dans 66 minutes et
qui dit que votre équipe a bel et bien
exhibé une arme devant kim kardashian
[Musique]
d'incompréhension commencé à crier allez
dans laquelle j'étais l'un de ses fils a
donc suffi on ne vend jamais les prix
alors vous porter une arme avec vos
complices domaine s'est dit que c'était
vraiment obligé de la ligue landon
justement c'est moi je suis toujours
perplexe sur larmes parce que moi nous
en vendons n'avez pas quand ils ont été
ensemble n'avaient pas parce qu'ils en
ont sorti une now
la junior moi je suis pas monté j'ai pas
été au contact de madame kardashian donc
le cambriolage quand même comment donc
vous y rendre vos complices contre il ya
le team car d'action dans la chambre le
sénat vous explique alice ce que j'en
sais bien sûr que moi je suis pas monté
et oui mais vous et j'ai eu des
informations et bien sûr vous n'êtes pas
monter ou non non non je suis pas devant
s'appelle votre livre j'ai séquestré à
vous n'êtes pas montré mais vous avez ce
que ça j'ai participé je suis confuse
dans la sphère après déjà joué
connaissent histoire ali le nist
ionisants qu'est-ce qu'ils devront que
quand on a immobilisé le concierge mes
deux collègues à moi l'ont pris sont
venus demander la clé la chambre il nous
a tout donné
la sq est normal il a tout donné
il a accompagné mes collègues et moi je
suis resté en bas à la place à la
réception pour vale pour recevoir les
gens si quelqu'un venait d'accord
j'avais joué donc le crawl aussi un
concierge
il y avait deux autres personnes qui
sauront qu'ils sont arrivés pour nous
soutenir nous aider en corse ont été
débordés d'accord n'hésitez pas habillé
en policier
comme l'a dit le reportage sont d'accord
ils sont trompés alors donc là vous que
vos complices ir ils ont la clé y rentre
dans la chambre de kim kardashian et
rentrer dans l'argent de l'hivernage ans
donc ce que le compte rendu qu'on va
faire après sûr c'est que lyon pression
téléphone est un téléphone elle avait
une espèce de voile sur elle elle était
assise en tailleur et le téléphone a été
tout seul elle était toute seule
d'accord ils ont vu personne d'autre
jusque dans la presse comme on a su
qu'il y avait la secrétaire nous
renverser portée personne n'est venu
qu'une incarnation d'un hyper fun donc
là elle a lyon 10e y compris là bas elle
était posée sur le bord du lit sur le
cheveu ou bref il leur a donné la bague
elle a pas résisté à la donne et ses
bijoux son coffre à bijoux
d'accord ils ont près et l'ont
activement attaché les mains avec du
scotch et l'ont jeté sur le sur le lit
ils ont laissé sur le lit son parti seul
avec sa bague
pour 9 millions d'euros oui non mais je
dis bien la baraque plus donc 9 millions
d'euros de butin
mais tu les bijoux n'était pas n'étaient
pas les siens